[Music]  you've done so many great things on SNL  one of your standouts is a terrific  Miley Cyrus impression that you how did  you have you first of all you've worked  with Miley is that yes yes I have and  she's always so great about it  and actually the last time the last time  she was on the show we did we did Miley  Cyrus together and she like asked me to  like kind of help coach her on the  impression of Miley Cyrus Miley Cyrus  wanted hope from you are being Miley  Cyrus so what did you tell her what I  was you know I just like kind of did the  voice for her and I was like you know  really move your mouth a lot and and  like big smile you know is the key move  your mouth let's move your mouth a lot  southern accent and just kind of like go  for it yeah yeah yeah and so she like  that yeah yeah  so she yeah so she was into it yeah you  helped her be a better mileage